- Hello everyone.
Nice to see you all here.
Hope everyone got to Vegas safely
and ready for a great re:Invent.
My name is Prashanth Ganapathy
I'm a Senior Solutions Architect with AWS.
I've been with AWS for
about five years now.
I just completed five years,
but I've been in the
solution architecting role
for about 20 years now.
And my claim to fame is I was doing AI/ML
before it was cool like three years ago,
so helping customers in AWS
with AI/ML technology
since I joined in 2020.
But I'm excited to be here today
and share Slack's journey
of their Developer Experience group
and their internal developers,
how they used Generative AI
and then eventually agents
over the last couple of years
and what kind of success they saw.
And that's what we'll be sharing today.
With me is Srivani and
Mani from AWS and Slack
and I'll let them introduce themselves.
- Thank you Prashanth, hello
everyone, I'm Srivani Bethi.
I'm a Staff Software Engineer
on DevXP-AI team at Slack.
I've been with Slack for about seven years
and I've been on DevXP-AI
team for about three years.
So today I'm very excited to
share some of our learnings
and journey in developing AI tooling.
- Awesome.
- Thanks Srivani,
Mani here I lead the
strategic ISV accounts,
the GenAI, the cool stuff.
I've been working with AWS for five years
and like this entire journey I've worked
with some of our largest ISV providers
and our product teams.
So basically helping
customers put their ideas
into actual work
and then helping our product
teams develop their roadmap.
So consider me as a bridge
between the customers
and our product teams.
And today here to share
about all the good work
that we did with Slack.
That's what the session
is going to be all about.
So before we get started,
quick show of hands,
how many of you checked
your Slack before coming in?
Exactly, Slack is where I would
say the work truly happens.
You know, we get into
conversations, this is where ideas,
you know, turn out, they become decisions.
Decisions become actions in turn
and every idea that turns into action,
the teams are talking, building
in Slack every single day.
And because of that,
Slack can never slow down.
They have to be fast,
they have to be reliable,
and they have to be secure.
All of this at a scale.
Now, as Slack continues
to grow across different
enterprises across the world,
the innovation becomes
absolutely critical.
And that's what I would say AWS comes in.
You know, AWS came in
and helped Slack develop
and build things faster.
It helped, it unlocked the
new levels of innovation.
So in this session we'll
talk about how Bedrock kind
of became the foundation that powers
and governs this next chapter for Slack.
And I love the quote from Andy Jassy,
which says that "together AWS
and Slack are giving
developer teams the ability
to collaborate and innovate faster."
Now this is quick and easy,
what we are gonna cover today.
First I'll share a little bit
about the Slack's Developer
Experience AI journey,
that's the Slack team using Bedrock.
Then we'll talk about
how Slack rolled out the
code assistant tools,
follow it up with the real impact
because I think that's important
on the developer community.
And then we'll explore
how Slack is now moving
into Agents and Strands.
And finally we close,
what's the road ahead?
What does it look like?
So by the end of this session,
you'll see not just what
Slack built, why they built it
and how they built it,
I promise no pop quiz at the end,
but hopefully you'll
get some few good ideas
that you can take back and
implement in your work life.
Now this slide is really about the people
behind the Slack
Developer Experience team.
The team that build this
integration, it exists
to make the life of
Slack engineers better.
They bring in AI closer to developers
and they remove the
friction from everyday work.
While we use Slack for
our day-to-day work,
how do we make the
developers much more agile
and much more productive?
So this journey started
by Slack Developer team building
something called Buddy Bot
to help build documentation, you know,
to help these developer answer
these questions more quickly.
And today this team touches
everything they build,
they touch the build and release tools,
they have the testing
infrastructure, they developer tools,
they develop these tools at scale
and they're roundabout,
I think Srivani like 70 to 80 people.
They are powering the entire
Slack engineering team.
And then, you know, even further
to the Salesforce organization.
What I would like to
highlight is what's powerful
about this team is that their approach,
they start internally fast.
So they kind of build
something, put it for a POC
or internal usage.
They roll it out at a
smaller engineering team
and once they are able
to prove it successful,
they roll it out to a bigger audience.
So this team is a huge
reason for Slack to move fast
and to move things very
quickly without breaking it.
Now before I jump into
Slack's journey, you know,
between Srivani and Prashanth
they're gonna talk about
how they implemented.
I quickly wanted to level set
on the AWS Stack that exists
that the team used to
build this entire solution.
So at the foundation level,
we have our Amazon SageMaker
and AI Compute
that basically Developer
teams can use to build,
train and deploy custom models
and they manage their own data and MLOps.
About this layer is our Amazon Bedrock,
which is a fully managed
foundation model layer.
Now this is where if the
teams want to move faster,
they want to experiment,
Bedrock gives you a choice
of leading model providers.
It gives you built in guardrails,
it has knowledge basis
for RAG, Retrieval-Augmented Generation,
and it has multiple
flexible hosting options.
Pay as you go.
You can probably, you know, pay up front
and all of this in the most secure way
that you can scale very quickly.
We also had launched AgentCore,
which handles a lot of,
you know, plumbing in the
end, like think about runtime,
identity, memory, observability.
All of this can be done through AgentCore
and by the team focuses
on the agent tech work.
Now on top of these are our SDK agents,
which is more like frameworks,
which we will talk about today,
the Strands Agents.
And we also have our first
party model called Nova Act.
And on top of all of
this finally is the layer
of applications like Kiro and Quick Suite,
which is like if you really want
to plug it in into your application,
you use these applications.
So that's like a complete stack
and we would be referring to some
of these while we talk
through the presentation.
So in simple terms, SageMaker
is where you build models,
Bedrock is where you can scale safely.
Strands is where you bring agents to life
and your top layer applications
is where you deliver.
So now with this in the
mind, let's move on to see
how Slack build a story.
One of my favorite slides
because it shows how Slack
actually build this step by step.
Now they, if you see this
started way back in Q2 of 2023,
almost like two years back with SageMaker
at this time it was all about learning.
GenAI was picking up, you
know, everybody was so excited.
So they started
experimenting, prototyping.
And this is probably the reason one thing
that the service SageMaker was Slack
has a really strict requirement
of being FedRAMP compliant
and SageMaker gave him that option.
And when it came to Q3
2023, they all started
with an Internal Hackathon.
And this is where things
got real, you know,
teams experimented, they built prototypes
and they even created things
like Huddle summaries.
I don't know if you
have seen that in Slack
that also a part of this Hackathon.
Now this is a phase which
was all about, you know,
proving the art of possible
what all you can do it.
And then Q1, 2024, Slack
moved to Amazon Bedrock
because Bedrock was now FedRAMP compliant.
All the latest Anthropic models
were available on Bedrock
and infrastructure got easier.
They really didn't have to
take care of infrastructure.
With Bedrock, it was like everything,
you just pull in a feature
and it's all taken care of.
All the undifferentiated
heavy lifting was done by them
and they nearly saved 98% of the costs
when they moved to Bedrock.
Now as they got familiar
with Bedrock, you know,
came Q2 of 2024, they came up
with the first bot called Buddy Bot.
And as I mentioned, this
is more like helping
with documentation, helping, you know,
developers find things more easily.
And the good part is while
they were building this,
they started using knowledge bases.
So nobody had to manage
their Vector source anymore.
Developers just got better on embeddings,
they got better knowledge
bases, they got faster answers.
Now as they build Buddy Bot by Q1 2025,
the developers being
developers, they started asking
for coding assistance, they
said, can we go further?
Can we build Coding Assistance?
And that is where Anthropic,
they started experiment
with Cursor and Claude Code.
And since Anthropic models
were anywhere available
and they were the
foundation of all the things
that they built, it was very easy for them
to use Claude Code and Cursor.
And they were adopted right on Bedrock.
And then finally in Q2 of, or finally,
but in Q2 of 2025, Slack
took a critical step
but obvious to build agents
because Agent Tech was
the new way to access data
through MCP servers.
They didn't rush into A2A
because they just wanted to
spend time learning that.
I said Slack didn't get
into analysis paralysis
they wanted to take it slow.
They built their first MCP Server
and they got into the
foundation of building agents.
And then in Q3, 2025,
Slack introduced Strands
and the Escalation Bot,
which Srivani is gonna talk
in more details, it's how
they move from Buddy Bot
to Escalation Bot using
Strands and Agents.
Strands is an open-source,
multi model agnostic
and flexible framework that we have.
And if you're on an agentic
journey, you know, we would love
for you to use that and
we'll talk more about it.
So I would just say the
biggest takeaway here is
Slack did not get stuck
in the whole analysis paralysis thing.
They kept experimenting,
they kept shipping
and they kept learning from it.
So today they have scaled
from processing a few
100,000 tokens per minute
to millions of tokens per minute.
It's just like basically
AI now instead of jogging,
it's sprinting all thanks
to Anthropics one million context window.
They just move from a few tokens
to million tokens in a minute.
Now the question is,
why did Slack ultimately
standardize on Bedrock?
Like why Bedrock?
I think first thing that they loved is
that it's a unified platform across AWS.
One, place to build, scale
and govern everything.
Second, I think it is very important
and it's Job Zero for us
is the built in security
that we have within Bedrock,
the guardrails that we have
and the governance that we have in place.
So guardrail, security, compliance,
it was all built in as a part of Bedrock.
And third was the massive scalability.
Slack isn't running one AI use cases,
it is running multiple UI cases,
AI cases across multiple
different organizations
with thousand, hundreds
and thousands of employees.
And all of this happened
without Slack needing
to worry about the infrastructure.
And I think that's the move from SageMaker
to Bedrock really helped them.
Now Bedrock led them
focus truly what matters,
building an amazing Developer Experience
and user experiences around it.
Now let's bring this home like
before I hand it over to Srivani.
In terms of impact, like
with an AI-assisted coding
using Cursor and Claude
Code on Amazon Bedrock,
Slack completely changed
how fast ideas turn
and were shipped into the actual features.
Quick show of hands, how many
of you think the productivity
would've gone up by 20%?
Nobody thinks, okay,
there's mine maybe 50%.
Is that too big of a number?
Oh wow, I have 50% more than,
okay, so here's what we know
for sure that it accelerated
the developer productivity.
It empowered the teams to innovate faster
and it massively reduced
the prototyping time.
But instead of guessing the numbers,
I'm going to hand it over
to Srivani who is going
to show you the actual numbers
and the real results
behind this infrastructure.
- Thank you, Mani.
I think one of the measuring impact,
how many of you here
have some kind of metrics
to measure AI impact on
developer productivity?
Cool, quite a few.
I think we are all talking about AI,
but I think one of the hardest
problem, hardest question
to answer is, is it actually helping?
I think in order to answer that,
we need to know what to
measure, how to measure.
So we initially started with
like two foundational metrics,
AI adoption, which means basically
if engineers are adopting AI tooling,
it's actually a first sign
of like it's helping them relieve pain
in one of their workflows.
The other part of it is impact
on Developer Experience metrics like DORA
and SPACE Metrics.
To measure these metrics,
we needed data from multiple data sources.
So we used Open Telemetry
Metrics, plumped into all
of our AI tooling to get the usage metrics
and some of the AI tool
calls and all of that.
We also measure metrics from
GitHub, our source code,
like pull requests and commits,
which are co-authored by AI
and also have some kind of AI signature.
So these metrics helped us
get like not a perfect metric,
but overall a good estimate of
how developers are impacted using AI.
Let's talk about the overall
developer impact here.
With all of the tools we have rolled out,
we have seen consistent
like week over week
adoption rates increase
and we've also seen consistent usage
of these tools month over
month for a few months now.
Currently 99% of our
developers are using some kind
of AI assistance, which is huge.
Once we got the adoption
numbers we are looking for,
then we started looking into
developer productivity metrics.
We started looking at PR throughput
and observed that some of the
major repositories we have,
we are seeing about 25% consistent
month over month increase
in the PR throughput.
There are also other metrics,
but this has been consistent.
The other metrics we are looking
into is AI Bot assistance,
which Mani just talked about.
It's a bot we rolled out
to help our engineers
with knowledge search and also help them
with the escalations.
So Escalations at Slack happen in Slack
when users have questions,
they come into Escal channels
and escalate it to the appropriate teams.
This was causing a lot of on-call
fatigue for our engineers.
So we rolled out AI assistance
to help engineers ease the on-call pain.
And currently our AI
assistance Bot is helping
over 5,000 escalation requests per month.
And the final metric
and the most important is
the qualitative metric,
which is the direct developer feedback.
And the feedback we've
been receiving confirms
that these tools are
actually helping developers.
I think with all of those tools
of course AI is not perfect.
We are also seeing downsides
of increase in peer review time.
As AI is helping
engineers write more code,
we are also seeing that the surface area
for review is increasing
and it's causing more load for developers.
We are actively working on this area
to reduce the review
time with AI assistance
and we are hoping we'll implement AI
to ease developer pain across all
of the developer cycle.
Learnings and experiences.
We have seen the metrics 99% adoption
and 25% PR throughput.
But the path to get here,
it wasn't a straight line.
Like many of you, we
started our AI journey
with experimentation,
with PR experimentation
like three years ago,
like Mani just talked about.
We built our initial capabilities
using SageMaker and RAG.
This gave us maximum control,
but it also came with a huge hidden cost
of infrastructure maintenance.
Our breakthrough came in
when we adopted AWS Bedrock.
This wasn't a technology change,
it also is a philosophy shift for us.
Bedrock instantly simplified
our infrastructure handling all
of the LLM scale and
infrastructure maintenance for us.
This change immediately addressed
our critical success factors for adoption.
Like security,
Bedrock allowed us to keep everything
within our AWS accounts
secure and also adoption.
So making LLMs available
through a proxy API,
we were able to provide LLM
access to all of our developers
to experiment using AI.
And the other one.
(indistinct chatter)
Oops.
- Is it working?
- It's working.
- Slides are not changing.
- It's not working, the slides are not.
The other advantage we also got
with switching to
Bedrock is observability.
So the inbuilt native
observability of Bedrock
of CloudWatch logs and metrics
and alerts helped us get
into some insights into our LLM usage.
Thank you.
Through our journey,
one of the main challenge
we faced was experimental,
experimentation fatigue with
different LLMs and tools.
The AI landscape is changing so fast
and we are struggling to keep up.
We realize that constantly rolling
out new competing internal features
was only causing confusion to developers
and also cost maintenance overhead for us.
So to combat that,
we doubled down on a high impact
tech stack, Amazon Bedrock
and Anthropic models and tooling.
We drove adoption by integrating
tools like Claude Code
and Cursor with Bedrock.
In fact, I think we were
one of the first teams,
our first company to roll
out Claude Code early
in Q2 of this year.
The goal here was to
create seamless experience
that maximizes throughput
and reduces the decision
fatigue for our developers.
Now I'm going to hand off
to my colleague Prashanth
to talk about Agentic frameworks.
- Thank you Srivani.
Those were some insightful and learnings
and some impressive
statistics right from Srivani.
As you all saw and heard
from Srivani and Mani,
Slack started the journey
in AI developer tools
and using Amazon Bedrock
and saw some impressive early success.
But I'm here to talk about the next stage
in the Agentic journey, right.
This is the year of agents, gotta hear why
and what they're doing with agents.
So quick show of hands, how many
of you here are exploring
agents in your organization?
Yeah, quite a few.
And how many of you have
agents running in production?
Alright, some of you maybe we
should talk to later as well
and learn from you, right.
So the key questions are, you know,
why agents, right?
Besides the obvious answer,
because everybody else is
doing it and we have to do it.
But for Slack there were
some key questions, right.
So as they were using these
coding assistant tools
and using the LLMs through APIs,
a lot of their actions were
Ad-Hoc workflows, right.
So they would, for example,
there's a issue going on
and would take the logs and
dump it into Claude Code
and say what's going on
and Claude Code would answer it, right.
But that's an Ad-Hoc workflow.
Now imagine on-call engineers
that are getting lots
of these requests, they
want automated runbooks
to be running, right.
So they want to take that to the next step
where agents are
processing what the ask is,
choosing the right tools,
making those decisions,
and then doing the, you know, analysis
and remediation, right.
So moving from Ad-Hoc to
Automated workflows was one
of the reasons and they were like,
we are already doing this,
we should just extend it.
The second part is, you
know, with just LLM calls
and doing ad-hoc flows,
it's not doing any
complicated reasoning, right.
It's doing LLM retrieval
and then maybe some post-processing,
but it's not doing any
complicated reasoning there.
It's not planning, it's not adapting.
That's another reason
to go towards agents,
especially in their environment
where they are, you know,
fixing things on the fly and
there are issues happening
and they have to react to it.
Also, Slack has built a lot of tools
and data sources on top of AWS services,
which they use effectively
for their data pipeline,
for their CICD build
for collecting logs, all of this, right.
So in order to take
advantage of all of this
in a dynamic fashion, they
would need to build some sort
of standardized access to this, right.
So agents would work
with something like MCP,
Model Context Protocol.
If you haven't heard of it,
you'll most probably hear
about it in this week.
So using a standardized protocol
to build out connections
and being able to
dynamically use these tools
and data sources, that's
another reason to build agents.
So these were the key
reasons why they were like,
we are already doing this
in an ad-hoc fashion.
We should standardize
this and automate it.
That was the key reason
for building agents
like the fancy font.
I wanted to show it for
the agents, you know,
so how, right,
so they were heavily using
Claude Code already, right.
So one of the key features
about Claude Code was
they were adding a lot
of agent capabilities,
especially the later half
of this year, features
like Claude Code subagents
and planning capabilities
and now skills has come out, right.
So they're adding agent capabilities
and they built an SDK, right.
So it's an agent with an SDK,
which you can use effectively
as subagents for various tasks.
So instead of building, you
know, agents from scratch,
which can do specialized
tasks, which is very complex
and it's hard to perfect,
right in production,
they started using Claude Code subagents
for a lot of these specialized tasks
that they're running into.
That was the first part they did.
The second part, like I said,
to access the variety of tools
that they have and the data sources,
they started building
out their own MCP Servers
and they also learned
some of that from us.
Like we built an MCP Server
for EKS, they learn how to use
that for some of their use
cases, things like that.
So being able to standardly
access, you know,
access all of these tools and data sources
without having, you know,
think about, oh I have to use this API
or I have to use that API, you know,
they wanna standardize it.
That was the idea.
And finally they were looking
at various agent frameworks
for integration and that's
where Amazon came in
and we'll talk about
Strands as we go along,
but that's how they
started exploring agents.
And then finally, you know,
what are they doing right now, right.
So one is instead of taking a giant leap
and building a super agent,
they're taking existing workflows
and which they built with LLM integrations
and they're enhancing it
to add more capabilities using
these agent tech workflows
and then also exploring new use cases
in their DevOps environments
as well as incident management
and things like that, right.
So that's what they're doing.
So these three steps, you
can see it's small steps,
but they're making progress
and they're putting things
into production, right.
Which is a very key step, right?
A lot of times we see
customers getting stuck
in analysis paralysis and we want,
and they're kind of moving
forward with these small steps.
So the key question, right.
When I was talking to
Srivani sometime back, right,
Claude Code and subagents are so powerful
and you can create automations
with it pretty easily SDK based.
So why look beyond something like that,
which is so powerful and it's meeting most
of their needs today, right.
That's a key question to ask.
We should not just adopt a new technology
just because it's there.
It should serve a purpose, right.
So we are kind of discussed that
and this was a key reason, right?
So one is it's great, right.
It's a great tool, but it
can get expensive, right.
It's got its own system prompt.
You can, you know, prompt it
with your own user instructions,
but it can get expensive.
It can get expensive
and it can be less predictable depending
on what you ask it to
do, that's one thing.
Also, you know, for Slack
and for everybody it should be
that you should be model agnostic, right.
Today it's Anthropic, tomorrow
could be something else.
We are so early in this journey,
we don't know what's going to come out.
So don't get, you know,
locked in into one technology.
So model agnostic is another part of it.
Right now people are
in exploratory phases,
so cost is not so much of a
consideration, but as production
as you roll this out into production
and the usage goes up,
the cost will become a big factor, right.
And so you may want to say,
oh for this specialized task,
why am I spending so much money?
I want to use you know, a cheaper LLM
and kind of pointed to that.
So if you get, you know,
just stuck with Claude code,
you may not be able to do that.
The other part is one of
the ideas which we discuss,
which Srivani will talk about is the idea
of the orchestrator region, right.
So Claude by itself and
Claude Code has the ability
to have its own
orchestrator, the planning,
the thinking capability and
then it can direct its subagent.
But now you're all into
Claude Code, right.
So what if you abstract it out, right?
What if you abstract out
the orchestrator away
from Claude Code and use
what is really good at
which is a subagent, right,
doing specific tasks.
So once you do that, now
this orchestrator agent,
which you have built
from scratch using a
open-source technology,
you are able to then point to
Claude Code subagent today.
But you can also point them
something else tomorrow, right.
That's the key, to abstract it out
and control what you're
accessing when you're accessing,
keep that within your framework.
That was another reason.
So finally by doing all of this,
you can create an agnostic agent framework
which will future proof your
production deployment, right.
That was the key.
So we went through this discussion
and then we kind of went into the journey
of the agentic world.
So that's where Strands comes in, right.
Strands is, I'll talk about
Strands and what it is,
but before we dive into Strands,
I wanted to discuss why
Amazon builds Strands, right,
an open-source data.
So while the potential of
agents is exciting, right,
everybody's wanting to build agents
and I've tried to build agents,
we have all been trying to build agents.
At some point you
realize it's more complex
than you think it is, right.
Everybody has gone through that,
raise up hands if you think it's resulted
in being more complex than
you thought it was, right?
Okay, many of you have not raised hands.
So I guess it's simpler
than we think it is.
So key challenges that
developers face, right,
with reliable agents.
One, there could be a steep learning curve
in building agents, right.
While we worked with
some of our customers,
we saw that they could
make simple use cases work,
but as it got complex and
the fact that new features
and technologies are coming
out every week, it's very hard
to keep up and decide, okay,
this is good enough for me
or should I wait for that
thing to come out, right.
That was happening a lot.
Enterprise and production
readiness, right.
So as you build stuff,
most of them will work great
in POC and demos, right?
But as soon as you take it to production,
there are a whole other set
of criteria that you have
to meet and that takes a much
longer cycle and we saw that.
Complex orchestration logic, right.
So again, a single agent or
an orchestrator calling one
or two agents with a couple
of tools works great as long
as soon as it goes to thousands of agents.
You as a company, if your goal
is not to just build agents,
it becomes much more complex.
And we'll talk about some
multi-agent patterns, right.
It does get complex in that stage.
And again, for production
it can be challenging.
Also lack of visibility, lack of controls,
not enough flexibility.
These are some common challenges
in most distributed systems
and you see that with
agents as well, right.
So there's a very early
stage in this technology
and so a lot of this, you want to keep it
in a framework which is open source.
That's why you open-source Strands, right.
So Strands is an open-source.
Initially we released a Python SDK,
you may hear some
announcements in re:Invent,
but initially we released our Python SDK
for building agents with
just a few lines of code.
And I'll show you some
examples as we go along.
It's simple to use, eliminates the need
for complex agent orchestration
and it's a code for a solution, right.
It's built keeping builders in mind,
developers in mind, right.
They can define a prompt,
select a list of tools
and then select the LLM
and then let it go, right?
That's how easy it is.
And by open sourcing we
aim to provide developers
with powerful flexible tools
to build agents in the rapidly
evolving agentic landscape.
So now that I've introduced Strands,
what are key features, right?
One is, like I said, model
and deployment choice, right.
It's open-source and while
the default LLM is Bedrock,
you can choose any third
party custom providers
and we have a list of them
and we keep adding more
to be used as the LLM
as part of the agent.
So we are not restricting
you from choosing the LLM
of your choice, right.
And also be able to deploy it anywhere,
any production agentic framework, right.
We are not restricting that either.
Highly flexible, it's
got built-in guardrails,
it connects to AWS's guardrail features
but other guardrail
features externally as well.
It's got built-in native observability
and monitoring hotel metrics
that you can stream out
if you use AgentCore,
it connects into AgentCore
automatically with these metrics.
So very easy to get visibility
and traces of these complex agentic flows
that happen, right.
Third, the MCP integration, right.
Model context protocol that sort
of become the industry
standard as we move forward
to connect into data sources and tools,
we provide that as well as there are a lot
of inbuilt tools in Strands itself
that you can use for a lot of tasks.
Add custom tools.
You can see on the integrations
we have integrations
with Mem0, Raga, stably,
Temporal, there's a Temporal
in AWS open-source session
happening somewhere else
in re:Invent you should
try to attend that.
So integrating a lot of these
third party services out there
to make it highly flexible, right.
So these are some of
the broad capabilities
that Strands has.
Before we go deeper into
how Slack used Strands
to you know, improve
their agentic workflows
or add agentic workflows, I did want
to talk about the multi-agent patterns
that exist within Strands.
You can see four of them,
I'm gonna talk about the starting to swarm
and the three, two to the right of them
and then I'll come back
to agent as tools, right?
So swarm is, as you can imagine,
collaboration between multiple agents.
So there are communication
patterns, shared memory systems,
coordination mechanisms,
and a host of agents are
talking to each other
to solve these complex problems.
A graph as again the name
suggests is you have the agents
which are Nodes and then
the way they communicate
with other agents are the edges
and you define explicitly
how they communicate, right.
So you can build out a
graph workflow pattern.
And then the final is the workflow,
which is essentially a
structured way of defining
how one agent will do one task
and pass it on to the next agent and so on
and so forth, right.
So these are three patterns that we have.
The fourth one on the
left, Agent as tools,
is the most interesting to us right now
because that's what Slack is using.
You heard me talk about
the orchestrator agent.
So we are using the orchestrator
agent in agent as tools
which handles the user interaction
and it decides which
specialized tool to call.
And these tools could be other agents,
that's why agents as tools.
And so the specialized
agents perform those tasks
and then hand back the answer
to the orchestration tool
to orchestration agent to
decide how to answer back
to the user, right.
So as Srivani will describe later on,
you look at how they use Strands
as the orchestrator agent
and our specialized agents
in Claude Code subagents
to do the specialized tasks.
So before we get into the
architecture discussion
that Srivani will talk about,
I did want to also, you know,
talk to you about what
Strands agent is, right.
It's a very simple concept.
Strands is what it calls
an agentic loop, right,
that forms the core of its functionality.
It receives a prompt and a
context along with a description
of the available tools,
then the model reasons about the tasks
and decides whether to respond directly.
Suppose it can respond directly,
it doesn't need the tools to respond,
otherwise it'll apply a series of steps,
reflect on previous actions,
select the tools that it needs
and do one of these steps
once it gets back the response
from the tool or whatever
it asks the task to do,
it decides whether the
task is actually complete
or else it'll repeat the cycle again
until the task is complete.
That's the basic nature of Strands,
how you create a Strands agent
and the multi-agent pattern.
So before I hand it back to
Srivani, I wanted to leave you
with a couple of just simple examples
of creating Strands agents, right,
with model choice and then I'll
show you the tools example.
So you can see over here
with a few lines of code,
you're able to create an agent
which uses a default choice,
which is Bedrock in this case
and a Nova model to create the agent
and ask that question.
And then similarly, you can attach tools,
you can see there are a whole host
of tool categories that is available.
And then from these tools
you can attach these tools
to the agent and create a simple agent
where in this case is
using the HTTP request tool
to ask a specific question, right.
So again, these are simple examples
but you can see to get
started very few lines
of code are needed and I
wanted to highlight that as to
how easy it is to get
started with Strands.
So hopefully you got a good
understanding of you know,
why Slack went towards agentic workflows,
why they selected Strands
as an exploratory area
to move forward with
and what it is solving
and also learn a little bit about Strands.
That was my part of the presentation
and now I'll hand it back
to Srivani to take it home
with the technical deep dive
starting with the Buddy Bot,
how they enhanced it with Strands
and then we'll get to Q&A, thanks
- Talk about the evolution
of our Buddy Bot technical deep dive
and to using Strands from
like the version zero
which we started.
Our story starts with
the fundamental pinpoint
of engineers spending a
lot of time on escals.
The initial Buddy Bot architecture
which was shown about,
was designed to handle basic
escalations by using knowledge
that is spread across
different data sources.
So as you see like the data sources
we are calling here is Slack
data, Slack messages and files
and also some of the technic,
some of the data is also scattered
across our GitHub repositories
like technical designs, documentation.
So as you see here, like
the first thing we did is
like we did a hybrid search.
So we gathered the right
relevant information
across all of these data sources
and then we in turn rerun those data
to get the more accurate
or more relevant data across
the knowledge sources.
And then we provide the
top most relevant documents
to the LLM with the user query
to provide a more accurate
answer back to the escalation.
So this was our first design,
which was working great,
but we ran into challenges
with the initial design
with respect to maintaining
the conversational history
and also being able to
execute external actions.
So then we evolved into what
you see here, the newer version
of our body which is
showing a powerful agent
but that we've built or we are exploring
which begins when a user sends a message,
our backend receives an event
and we start a Temporal
workflow orchestration
around that, which basically
main provides durability
as well as maintains
the conversational state
across the entire escalation
until it is resolved,
which releases the ease of pain
for maintaining the conversations for all
of the escals in our applications.
The Temporal workflow
which then calls the main
Strands orchestrator,
the Strands orchestrator agent
which we build using Anthropic as well,
Anthropic Claude model as well,
which then decides which subagents to call
and the subagents have access
to the MCP servers to interact
with our internal services.
All of the subagent that you see here,
we've built using Claude SDKs.
So the subagents are Claude,
the orchestration agent is,
so there is orchestration agent is Strands
and the subagent are Claude Code.
The reason we chose Strands
agent here as orchestrator is
to explore different LLMs, not
just use Claude Code subagent
as we're actively exploring
other competing models.
And once all of the subagents
are finished running,
the main agent, the orchestration
agent gets the context
or response back, which then
synthesizes its processes
and validates the response
before sending it back
to the Slack channel.
So as you see the flow here.
So we are gonna see a live demo of like
how it happens at Slack.
So when a user sends a question
or an escalation in Slack channel,
our backend gets an event
and then our backend then
spins off a Temporal workflow
which you see here,
which has the context of
all the Slack conversations
that happen or escalations that
happen in that Slack thread.
It then kicks off our orchestrator agent,
which is return using Strands.
And once the orchestrator
agent receives the request,
it actually sponsors subagents
through the tool call,
which Prashanth already just talked about.
As you see here, it's actually
calling the Triage agent
and KB agent.
Those are all subagents we
built using Claude Code.
And the good thing
with the Temporal is it
also provides visibility
into like all of the calls
and traceability as well.
So once the main orchestrator
agents processes everything,
its sensor response back to Slack channel.
And when a user asks a follow-up question,
all of the context of the
previous conversation is
actually maintained by Temporal,
which eases the pain on
the application itself
to maintain the conversation
history and the states.
So as you see Temporal
resumes the workflow,
whenever user sends,
continues the conversation
in Slack thread, it just
resumes the same workflow.
So once it finishes the same flow,
like the response is sent
back to the customer.
So this workflow simplified,
this architecture simplified
our Code quite a bit
as we didn't have to maintain
the conversational history
and durability of retries,
which is all provided by Temporal.
And with the Strands we
were able to experiment
with different subagents
and we were not had to
stack with just Claude Code.
So as you see, as you saw our overview
of the technical architecture,
we upgraded our Buddy Bot
from a simple search bot
into a powerful agent.
And some of the things we considered
while building it is
reliability and efficiency.
First we built a stable foundation,
we used Temporal for reliability
as the bot never forgets the conversation
even during failures, even
when the backend dies,
Temporal maintains the state in a database
so it resumes where it left off.
Temporal also supports like
retries, automated retries
so we didn't have to
retry tool call failures
and all of that in our
application, which eased
or simplified our code quite a bit.
And next we solved crucial
security challenge.
We created remote empty MCP servers
with IoT service which
integrates to Aruba proxy,
which is a networking system.
This ensures the bot
can safely access
sensitive internal systems
like GitHub with the right permissions.
Finally, we were focused
on making bot faster.
So we ran all of these
subagents in parallel
and we also optimized the
token usage management.
So the Strands subagent
before sending it to the LLM to summarize
and like confirm the response.
It summarized each of the
response from the subagents
to reduce the token management
across when sending it
to a very expensive LLMs.
And also Strands provided us extensibility
for any future being LLM agnostic.
So the road ahead, we've
stabilized the architecture
and solved the security problems
and optimized performance.
But this is just the foundation.
Our vision is much bigger
than single Escalation Bot.
We are on a road
to establishing fully
automated agentic workflows
across the entire development cycle.
We would like to experiment
StrandS use cases
beyond escalation
and we would like to integrate
more internal tools via MCP
to make our bots more,
our agents more powerful.
We also are exploring AgentCore
and we would like to have
native integration with Temporal
and Strands agent first,
smoother execution
and also more granular retries.
Our long-term goal is simple,
but ambitious of fully
Automated Agentic workflows
across the entire development cycle.
Here are some of the links for you all
to get started building agents.
- Yeah, I can.
Yeah, thank you again.
And yeah, I'll keep it here a minute
and then we can take Q&A after that.
So if you want to get the QR codes,
I'm sure you'll run
into a lot of these links
throughout re:Invent.
Please don't forget to fill out the survey
in your mobile app and then
we will just move to Q&A.
- Yeah, and all of these
sessions that you see,
if we go back on the QR
code, if you think any
of these topics are interested,
we have multiple sessions going on
across next two or three days,
so please feel free to look
around the different session.
Their Keynote, Swami will
be making a ML Keynote,
definitely watch that.
A lot of new announcements
coming in across Asian Codes,
Strands, and Bedrock.
- [Prashanth] Yeah, thank you.